when the water meters get checked here
in hell alia Lebanon it makes for
interesting reading the district in the
city of Sidon is running a pilot scheme
water is usually paid at a yearly flat
rate of about a hundred euros per
household
but since authorities started to measure
water use some people's bills have been
going up those who use more pay more
Vibha see if we had the MSS and I'm the
most little height of water costs go up
for washing or if I'm growing something
in the garden and need water but I can
accept that I pay more no mizerock I'm
not a bot above me Sudan is a city of a
hundred and sixty thousand people there
are plans to install water meters more
extensively in the city the aim is to
conserve precious water
statistics show that each person here
uses an average 135 liters every day a
bit more than in Germany around 20% of
that could be saved when you hear that
spending on the water supply over the
next 15 years is estimated at about four
billion dollars well if you can save 20%
of that you can save about eight hundred
million dollars on spending that just
isn't necessarily indeed an item is not
indeed we are
money is urgently needed to update the
waterworks in Sedona as well as the
national water grid many areas of
Lebanon only get water for a couple of
hours a day another problem is the
amount of water that leaks into the sand
the seed on waterworks treats 40,000
cubic meters of water a day
mingi that from that amount less than
half is effectively used by customers a
large part is lost through defective
pipes and we can assume that no small
amount is siphoned off illegally but
building new pipes is expensive and
takes time in cities like see Don German
experts have a simple solution for
saving water in the short term a 35000
euro mechanism that lowers the water
pressure at night when demand is lower
that means less water is lost through
leaks
the range powerful fatigue it saves us
roughly a thousand cubic meters per day
that's five or six thousand bathtubs
full of water every day so it really is
a significant amount of water that can
be saved by this that means costs come
down and can be reflected in residents
water bills in the newly built call
center customers have a point of contact
for any complaints or to report needed
repairs south Lebanon water wants to
give its customers and awareness of the
value of water a lot of people and put
in their minds that this is a
governmental issues any no need to pay
and we can take the water and we don't
pay or we steal the water we need to
work hard in convincing the people the
importance of protecting the water
Sayid Issa he says he used to spend
hours watering his garden like this
these days he doesn't much more
sparingly that's because his water usage
shows up on the meter and on his bill is
the octave title it's been accepted
fairly well so far we haven't had a
revolution and I think this is the way
forward for the country we'll try to do
it in other areas too and to slowly
bring in water meters in the rest of the
country
the goal is to provide all of Lebanon
with adequate water 24 hours a day it
will take 10 years but they've made a
start